for
r there is something fundamentally wrong
here uh Denmark uh Germany
and
and oops if the EU cannot even reach an
agreement with a country such as Canada
a country with similar environmental and
labor standards what hope do we have for
telling the rest of the world that the
EU is open for business we Europeans we
have something to be proud of we have
been leading for many decades uh in the
area of democracy the rule of law and
fundamental
rights
for
number of what we call unaccompanied
miners reached a record of more than
95,000 last year the truth is that often
those children who surviv the journey
find themselves in no man's land alone
vulnerable and easily
exploited
zarov
prad A bash
for